Hello, welcome to another members minute. This is Michelle Hamburger, and I'm here with Dr. Connors
We are talking today about natural sweeteners with the holidays looming and people doing a lot of baking and
looking for sweet
options that aren't going to be harmful to their cancer diet
We're wanting to explain some of the differences between what are healthy options for natural sweeteners and
What would be best to stay away from so Dr. Connors your thoughts. Okay, so we all want a decreased sugar
Whether you have cancer or not. It's a good idea to decrease your sugar content
And when you're talking about decreasing your table sugar
We're really talking about decreasing the about a circulating
glucose glucose that's circulating your bloodstream and that has to do with an index called your glycemic index
There's certain foods that break down into glucose
Faster than others. So this picture right here of sugar sugar is sucrose
Which are two different sugar molecules bound together glucose is
A single type of sugar that goes into the crev cycle and can feed cancer growth and can feed other things if we have too much of it
So that's what causes diabetes all cybers and get a feed cancer
So it's not just table sugar that we're trying to eliminate, but what we're talking about in this little bit
It is what to use in a substitute or table sugar in recipes so that you can have a treat them and then without feeling like you're
depriving yourself from anything good
So the first thing that we have to touch on because most our patients know this but a lot of other people don't is these bad guys
So these are artificial
Sweeters that are on the market and I included true via it here even though that's a stevia product
This is a stevia product that is made by a large food company that uses a GMO
stevia, so I
Do not recommend this type of stevia even though stevia would be called are okay less to which you'll see in a second
But all these other ones are artificial sweeters that are very sweet and are used, you know
People use sweet-low with their coffee and use these different things
But only use these these artificial sweeters if you want to get cancer
So if you really want to get cancer you don't have cancer that use these and you could
Be facetious, but it is very dangerous, right?
We don't want to be using any artificial sweeters
So this is just a given to anybody knows anything you want to appreciate. You don't use that stuff
So here's some seven sugar substitutes. There's more, but here's some things that you could use
So honey agave nectar pure maple syrup these are the kind of the go-to's typically right here
We're not a big fan of agave nectar because it has some other issues that we work gonna get into on this
little topic
Honey is a good one because it's natural, but for our cancer patients, we typically recommend the manuka honey or at least use a raw
Honey when you're gonna use this as a substitute
And the pure maple syrup if you can use a grade B if you can find grade B and ask more nutrients in it
Otherwise, the grade A used a
Food local source pure maple syrup if you can
Unsweetened apple sauce does mix nice with a lot of different recipes, but it is mixed nice with a lot of different recipes
Coconut sugar is a nice alternative to though this does all these things understand all these things are gonna break down to glucose
So it's still using with in moderation
The only thing that won't is this one right here. This is stevia. So stevia is an herb
Problem with using stevia a lot of people don't like it because it's got such a different effort after taste
And it's very difficult to substitute in recipes because just a pinch of stevia could be equivalent to sweetness of a half a cup of sugar
And it's like how you substitute the recipes have turned out very well with that
So and some people don't like the way stevia tastes, but if you could get used to the way stevia tastes
If this is probably your one that's gonna decrease that's gonna not increase your glucose levels more than any of these
dates are a good substitute and that they have good
Some good minerals in them, but they're very high in sugar
So you do it to be careful just you see this is what the one substitute
Some people have used
Different herbs as a substitute for sweetness even though it doesn't have a sweetness to it
Like using vanilla extract as a substitute for
Increasing this and decreasing the amount of sugar and one nice thing with the holidays is if you just start getting used to
Not eating sugar, but then you could actually
Half or two third reduction of the sweet
The sugar in your recipes, and you still may think it tastes as good. Yeah
There is truth to that whole idea of you become accustomed to the sweeter that items are and the more that you back away from it
You realize just how overly sweet the foods that are on the market have become and
How little sweetener you really need for most of the foods that are out there another creative thing to do
also is to add
Fiber to the thing that you're making so let's say if you're making banana bread and that's your staple for Christmas that you make
Banana bread every year well half the sugar and add a fiber content because remember from a glycemic it's
Index point of view
Every gram of fiber in a product will offset a grab of sugar on how fast it breaks down
So by increasing the fiber content like maybe if you're juiced
You could take the leftover pulp and add it to your bread or add it to your cookies because that's a fiber
And that will help offset some of the glucose content too
That sounds great. Well, thank you very much. I know the one thing we did. I know this was xylitol
xylitol is a sugar alcohol and
That tends to be a favorite for
Sugar subs to shoot as well
And the thing that I want you about xylitol is get the birch
Derived as isletal that the corn derives xylitol
Most isletal that's on the market is corn derives. Therefore, it's going to be geobo
Derived and it's not nearly as beneficial as the birch derived
xylitol carries issues too. Some people have sensitivities to it and it could cause diarrhea
So there's just there's issues with that too. So just be careful with that as well
Would whether it's birch derived or corn deride be typically notated on the back of the ingredients list?
You can find it while you do order it usually if they don't have a if they don't list it then it's you can almost guarantee it's corn derived. Okay
All right, thanks a lot. Thank you